les jo dassin se sont donné rendez vous
mardi 28 janvier pour rencontrer les
acteurs du film
je ne rêve que de vous qui retrace
l'histoire d'amour de léon bim et jeune
rachel bac la projection du film était
suivie d'un débat avec l'équipe du film
léon blum est une grande figure de jouy
en josas
et j'aime bien l'histoire ma mère elle
m'a dit qu'il y aura elsa zylberstein et
d'autres personnes de cinéma du coup bah
ça m'intéresse pour le débat à la fin
emmi elsa zylberstein dans le rôle de
jeanne bloom est venu introduire le film
dans sa ville natale
ça fait genre en 25 ans je suis pas
rentré dans cette salle des fêtes
donc ça m'émeut énormément c'est
l'endroit où je faisais mes gars là
dedans quand j'étais petit ça me fait
quelque chose de jouer une amoureuse
comme ça une famille répressive vivante
vibrante c'est toujours voilà c'est
toujours des rôles magique pour le
réalisateur du film
tout a commencé dans la commune de jouy
en josas quand il a visité la maison de
jeanne et léon blum
j'ai visité la maison léon blum au
moment de son inauguration et j'avais
été j'avais déjà ce projet de film en
tête
le film se termine
à la maison léon blum sauf que c'est un
décor de cinéma évidemment mais voilà je
suis très content très ému en plus je
trouve qu'il ya une atmosphère très
joyeuse dans la salle on aperçoit une
invitée un peu particulière qui est venu
voir le film pour la sixième fois la
petite fille de jane blum gelé très très
bien dans toutes lés cette histoire donc
évidemment je suis là et je suis très
très très ému de le revoir à jouy en
josas en plus où j'ai vécu 15 ans un
film qui rend hommage à l'histoire du
couple blum mais aussi à leur maison
devenue musée dans la commune de jouy en
josas
je ne rêve que de vous sorti le 15
janvier 2020 est toujours projeté dans
les salles